Hello, everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to Bowman 2.
Now, I apologize for the videos being late today.
Uh, last night I had sort of a health thing happen...
I'm not going to go into details, but it's nothing life threatening.
I didn't need to go to the hospital or anything,
but it took me out of commission for a few hours.
Uh... so I couldn't record last night,
and I have to record today.
That's why it's late.
I'm totally 100% okay... nobody panic!
I'm just explaining why the videos are late today.
But this is Bowman, and I love Bowman
because, uh, when I was in college...
Uh, instead of studying and working hard at the college courses I was at,
I was in the computer lab,
and I would always play this game.
It got so bad that one time,
my professor... actually came up behind me...
He snuck up on me!
He's a sneaky old man!
He just came up behind me and creeped up on me.
But he asked me what the hell I was doing,
and so I just ended up explaining the game to him
while everyone else in the class was looking at me
and it was super awkward.
But then he said he tried the game for himself, and he enjoyed it!
So...
I think you'll enjoy it too.
So, the basic premise is that you are
a bowman.
And I've added wind, you can in add different features.
You can add wind, and a wall and that may not make a lot of sense to you
but basically,
you're trying to fire this bow.
And you can calculate your angle
and your power,
one of the easier ways to do it is just max out 100% power,
and then go by the angle.
So if I know where this guy is...
HEUGH!
But the distance- WHOA!
I was- I was not looking at the angle!
I was just trying to explain.
Ow, my FOOT, you bitch!
I think it was like 14? So 14.88.
Bink!
Okay..
Well, he dead!
*laughing* Oh shit!
I didn't even know that!
Basically, the distance between you and the computer, they randomly, uh, generate
so it's- it's different depending on what game you play.
It'll go- like, I got lucky that round.
I got super lucky.
I'm pretty sure it's not going to be the same place again.
Okay, yeah. So he changes position...
And one of the reasons it's easy to do just 100%
because it- it- it removes a factor that you have to calculate for-
UGHH, right in the NECK.
I- I'm not paying attention to the numbers,
I'm trying to actually talk to you guys.
But if you hit him..
a few times...
Boink- what?!
That went right through his body!
Why didn't it hit him?!
What the hell was that??
Alrighty then...
Let's try that once more...
Through your heart! Okay.
So you hit him...
And you can either get a headshot, or go right through the heart,
and you'll win,
and you know you win because
spouts of blood start shooting outta there.
OR
You can do what I try to do sometimes,
and just try to get as many arrows
into his testicles as possible
before the game ends.
And to do that you gotta aim a bit lower than usual.
Come at me, bro!
Ah, you ain't never gonna get me.
See, the wind adds a little bit extra
uh, because-
ooh, shit.
Because, for me..
uh, it- it just means that you can't- whoa,
that was close to my head.
I t just means that you can't go off of what the computer does...
always?
Eeeugh.
Little lower! I just need to go a little lower to get to the balls,
and hopefully he won't turn me into a pin cushion...
Before I turn his testi-cules [testicles]
into a pin cushion.
Boink! Aw, man.
I thought that was higher.
I keep going right through the heart!
I'm too good at this!
Yeah.
*mumbling Mark noises*
Like, th- the other thing to do,
like, the hundred strategy
is actually kind of...
It's kind of bullshit.
Because...
Uh, i-it removes a factor and it's almost always the same.
But I just wanna get...
I wanna get- whoa he's really close this time.
I just wanna get arrows into his testi- okay.
That was my face. Thank you very much.
HI-BIFF!
Ugh, your knee!
You took Skyrim to the knee!
Ow- MY knee!
You son of a bitch.
I'm gonna blast you right in the balls!
*laughing* There we go! That was the stuff.
A'ight.
You- you prepare, because you're in for a world of hurt.
I got this locked in at 5 point- what was it?
(murmuring) I dunno what it was.
There we go!
5.5!
*laughing* Got it!
So I don't know if I can win. I can't remember if I can win
if I get enough... into his ball..
Uughh
*laughing* Ugh, right in the junk.
Right in the grundle area.
Let's see...
I think, uh- I think if you get four... right?
Yep. If you get four, he'll bleed profusely
*laughing* from his groin area until he dies.
So anyway, that's that.
Uh, an- and there's another....
There's another way to play. If you go into the settings,
you can add wind or a wall.
And the wall...
is a bit more interesting when you play
because you're not just doing it at a hundred,
you gotta get over- whoops.
You gotta get over this wall,
which randomly generates its height
and I dunno if the computer can compensate for that.
I forget if it can.
Usu- you can play this against other people, but it doesn't have any online functionality,
so you gotta- got just- y'know... do your thing,
and now I'm overshooting by far.
Yeah, don't even wait for my arrow to get done.
Thanks, buddy.
Ok so you gotta...
Okay, so now you gotta calculate the angle AND the power...
so 60 by 45 is not enough.
Uh- I'll keep it at 60 degrees because
that's probably a good angle.
So 60 by...
54...
EeeEEERRRBoink!
Okay, 60 by...
58 would probably be good enough.
Boink!
Huuuu-boof!
*laughing* Hey-ey I go- Oh!
Did I get his heart?
Ow!!!
My head! Who won?!
Oh, I won!
But he got a shot off so we both died .
Eh okay anyway. So the- the only one other
game mode in this-
and I highly recommend playing this.
It's totally a free game,
it's back in the days of free flash.
But there's... there's
bird hunting mode,
which is...
Boink! Whoops!
Eup, first off with a miss- welp!
Second off with a miss!
YOU'RE NOT GETTING AWAY THAT EASY!
Ah shit, he's getting away that easy.
Boink.
Hep. Boink!
Gotta REDEEM my TITLE!
As, I dunno what, but.
Somethin'.
Somethin' somethin'!
(high pitched) Boink!
Whoa, shit.
How did I kill myself?!
Why is there a bird attached to my head??
Oh god, I'm just getting bird trophies.
Boink- oh shit. Boink!
What I- what you CAN do is you can spear two in a row.
It's kinda rare, but I can do it.
(high pitched) Boink!
Oh shit... boink!
Aaah fuck. Boink!
Aaah shit!
There we go. Got you!
Ah shit!
HEUP-
Ah fuck!
*incoherent Mark noises*
TtthHHERE we go, got two in a row!
So...
Basically it's a time waster!
But it's a very good time waster.
And I love time wasting!
Because... screw actually doing work.
Who needs to!
But either way, that is Bowman.
I highly recommend trying it for yourself.
It's a lot of fun!
I mean, what's the harm?!
Check the link in the description below!
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
And I'll get the second video out pretty soon.
I'm gonna actually be playing probably the Outlast 2 demo
because I finally got my hands on it, but we'll see what happens. So...
Thank you everybody so much for watching!
And as always, I will see you...
in the next video!
Buh bye!!!
*Outro music playing: 'Crazy La Paint'*